chacun et luc ferry
non non
messieurs comment ça va c'est bien ici
regardez votre pire mais ça commence pas
mal ça commence sympa ouais vous
regrettez pas de clé de ministre
l'éducation nationale non non et non non
non mais cela dit je regrette pas
d'avoir été non plus à dégraisser le
mammouth un peu avant de partir je
craque la bête soit restée en l'état
personne n'est parfait et en plus vous
avez vu ce qu'ils vous ont succédé ils
ont pas eu plus de chance que vaut un
oui c'est vrai que je m'aperçois que
j'ai une longévité assez assez
remarquable puisque les autres ont giclé
haussier ce barème fillon qu'est ce qui
met un nom un an et c'est que j'ai pu
tisser j'attends c'est qu'ils sont
méchants quand même alors alors été
arrêtées et catherine barma me dit dans
l'oreillette gilles de robien
bah oui je le comprends et perben mois
ils se ressemblent un peu à l'écart des
amoureux c'est bizarre avec sa famille
la paroisse saint mich vous savez ça
nous l'a montré ici c'est mon troisième
saindon peur ils sont pâles signé trois
comme ça non yana tu sais pas ça qui va
lier les deux 10la 200 et 1 qu'est la
barre mais oui c'est vrai il nous a
montré une image dans la tête la
poitrine à quel point
vraiment voilà le dos célibataire vous
n'êtes pas célibataire bon c'est à noël
et la ba konaré a validé la absolue
morlaàs nous surveille non non mais
enfin n'est pas loin quand même invité
la mairie caroline bien
bras-panon
oser
maman est dans le coin elle est à la
maison et elle garde les enfants
voilà la paire une femme un si joli on
l'invitera de là tout est dit ça va très
bien très bien
et alors dites-moi commencé depuis qu'il
est plus ministre vous avez tout à vous
alors c'est bien oui je l'avais déjà
tout un - ouais ouais et alors d'agir
il va pas souffert de sa non pas du tout
non et bien ouais et vous êtes tous
maintenant aux castes c'est quoi le
casse c'est une chose qui s'appelle le
conseil d analyse la société sts à
matignon rec auprès du premier ministre
et ce assez
c'est en fait très sympathique parce que
j'ai la chance d'être entouré d'une
trentaine de personnes personnalités de
la société civile ça va david douillet à
danièle thompson en passant par des
historiens des chercheurs des
biologistes des médecins et on travaille
sur les questions de société par exemple
le prochain rapport qu'on publie c sur
les cellules souches
baguet je peux changer vos places la
vienne vous mettez là parce que j'ai oui
parce que avant pourquoi pas maintenant
on sait quoi marie caroline c'est de ta
viens avec moi et les questions
sexuelles après mais voilà merci
fabienne voilà à tous les deux longueurs
des champins garder comme ils sont beaux
là
bien alors vous publié chez plon un
livre qui s'appelle apprendre à vivre
c'est un petit traité de philosophie à
l'usagé des jeunes générations
laurent baffie tu vas suivre là parce
que normalement tu dois arriver à suivre
il a fait pour sa fille elle a quel âge
elle avait 12 ans à l'époque donc lui
falloir être édifié d'accord pour m
alors qu'est ce que la philosophie
on a beau même temps une hernie mais moi
je vais te le dire
la philosophie c'est l'autre réponse à
l'angoissé des hommes la première étant
la religion évidemment et c'est un salut
sans dieu la philosophie voilà c'est ce
que vous dites dans votre site à
s'illuminer c'est assez simple comme
définition alors ça paraît idiot mais
j'ai mis trente ans à comprendre
vraiment ça et l'idée que je développe
dans ce livre et qui me permet de
raconter à des gens qui n'ont jamais
fait philosophie vraiment l'histoire de
la philosophie en rentrant quand même à
fond dans les grands grande vision du
monde
c'est l'idée que on part évidemment tous
d'un certain nombre de peurs on a des
valeurs qui sont ça peut être les peurs
qu'on a devant un personnage célèbre
quand on vient d'un milieu modeste ça
peut être les peurs qu'on a quand on a
des phobies par exemple c'est ce que
l'état oblige les toques n'importe
et puis il ya une grande peur qui nous
malgré tout qui nous anime tous c'est
évidemment la peur de la mort pas
simplement la sienne mais surtout
souvent la peur de la mort des eaux des
gens qu'on aime et cette question là on
n'en parle pas beaucoup la cache souvent
mais les grandes religions ils y ont
répondu m elles sont des cibles et des
doctrines du salut avec dieu elles vous
disent au fond mais tu n'auras plus peur
si tu te mets dans la main de dieu et
que tu te laisse porter par la croyance
et la croyance ça veut dire aussi la
confiance et les grandes philosophies
moi je vous dis une chose ça n'est rien
d'autre qu'une tentative de répondre
exactement la même question sur comment
se débarrasser de la peur et nos temps
de la peur de la mort avec l'idée qu'on
ne peut bien vivre que si on se
débarrasse des peurs mais essayer d'y
répondre sans faire appel à dieu voilà
autres bandits non pas par la foi mais
par la raison alors lu que vous racontez
les cinq grands moments de l'histoire de
la philosophie et c'est assez
intéressante parce que on voit bien
l'évolution humaine
tiens que vous commencez avec la
philosophie antique alors la naissance
de la philosophie en fait c'est né en
grèce au vième siècle avant jésus-christ
qu'on appelle le miracle
drake et jusque là les religions
détenait le monopole et là c'est la
première recherche rationnelle donc vous
dit sans doute parce que la cité avait
une nature démocratique c'est ça oui
parce que la démocratie est là elle a
engendré chez les chez les humains en
grèce
cette volonté d'argumenter de démontrer
d'essayer de d'échanger des opinions et
par conséquent la philosophie est
certainement né en relation avec cet
univers dans lequel on avait pris
l'habitude de débattre de discuter
encore une fois d'argumenter est donc
d'essayer de comprendre le monde et de
répondre à cette grande question du
salut par la raison plutôt que par la
foi et la première grande réponse
philosophique à la question de la peur
de la mort et comment s'en débarrasser
c'est la réponse des grandes visions du
monde qui sont développés à partir de
peut-être le premier grand philosophe
parménide qui est qui et le philosophe
qui va dominer la pensée avant platon
jusqu'à jusqu'au grand stoichkov jusqu'à
françois valéry qui disait et non
aimons-nous vivante
alors il ya un truc moi qui m'a surpris
c'est que la philosophie antique grecque
est assez proche du bouddhisme
finalement parce que l'essence du monde
c'est l'harmonie c'est le cosmos les
grands mots si la nostalgie et
l'espérance il faut vivre l'instant ses
traits et bouddhiste non attachement aux
possessions ou bien ce monde seulement
est ce qu'est ce que la philosophie
grecque a inspiré le bouddhisme vous
croyez pas ce que c'est la même chose
non je pense qu'ils se retrouvent sur
des grands thèmes et vous avez tout à
fait raison de dire s'il ya une très
grande proximité entre la philosophie
stoïcienne en particulier puis le
bouddhisme nous explique ça en deux mots
les grecs en particulier stoïcienne
niveau ils imaginaient que le nom de ce
qu'ils appelaient le cosmos engrais que
ça veut dire un ordre simplement était
comme un organisme vivant que tu sais
quand un physiologiste ou un médecin
ouvre un organisme vivant
il voit que tout est merveilleusement
bien fait que les choses sont à leur
place quand vous regardez un oeil c'est
incroyablement bien fichu les poumons
tout est merveilleusement bien fait et
les grecs s'imaginait que l'ensemble du
monde était cet ordre qui était c'était
enfin gros êtres vivants si vous voulez
et le but de la philosophie c'était deux
choses c'est tout simple un comprendre
cet ordre le contempler essayer de
comprendre comment il marche et 2
trouver sa place sa juste place à
l'intérieur de cet univers
merveilleusement ordonné magnifiquement
fait et quand on avait trouvé sa place
dans le monde comme le cosmos pour les
grecs le monde était éternelle eh bien
on s'apercevait d'une chose très
importante c'est que la mort n'était
qu'un passage et qu'au fond c'était une
transformation d'un état en un autre et
ça permettait justement un peu comme
dans le bouddhisme de vaincre cette peur
primaire qui est la peur de la mort et
donc le but de la philosophie c'était un
de comprendre le monde de 2,6 ajusté
c'était toute la fois les 3 pourquoi et
bien justement pour vaincre la peur de
la mort pourquoi le christianisme a t'il
vaincu cette philosophie grecque parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas aristocratique et
on se rend compte que le christianisme
ont fait c'est l'invention de la
démocratie c'est-à-dire l'égalitarisme
dire tous les êtres humains sont égaux
alors les grecs avaient en effet l'idée
que le monde était hiérarchiser qui
avait une hiérarchie naturelle des êtres
il était dans un monde aristocratique ce
que la morale chrétienne va inventer qui
est génial qu'on voit dans la parabole
des talents dans l'évangile en
particulier c'est l'idée que comment
dire la dignité des êtres humains ne
dépend pas des talents naturels du fait
qu'on soit excellent parce qu'on peut
très fort on peut très beau on peut être
très intelligent tout ce que vous voulez
comme talent naturel mais on peut en
faire le pire usages qu'ils soient
l'idée c'est que c'est que en gros la
dignité d'un être humain ne dépend pas
de ses talents naturels au départ ça
c'est la vision aristocratique du monde
mais la dignité d'un être humain dépend
de ce qu'il en fait de ce point de vue
là on est tous à égalité quelle que soit
la base de départ ce qui compte c'est ce
qu'on va en faire et là d'une certaine
façon en effet les chrétiens à vente la
première morale démocratique c'est la
première mort à nous nous sommes tous à
égalité à la sens du monde
aristocratique l'esprit est plus
important que la lettre c'est à dire que
jésus défend la femme adultère malgré la
loi
et ça c'est génial parce que moi je suis
pas chrétien mais franchement si j'avais
un livre à emporter sur l'île déserte
j'emporterai l'évangile de jean et en
particulier je trouve cet épisode qui
est vraiment relisez l'elysée le ces
magnifiques parce que dans le texte vous
savez c'est la femme adultère elle va
être lapidée donc il ya tous les types
qui sont là qui vont la lapider et dans
le texte vous voyez le christ qui se met
en dehors du cercle des gens qui vont
lapider cette femme
il se met à jouer comme ça ils jouent
avec le sable et c'est symbolique du
fait qu'ils se met en dehors de la loi
de la cité pour essayer de faire valoir
l'esprit et dit aux gens au fond mais
attendez vous vous apprêtez à lapider
cette femme mais regardez en vous même
est ce que vous êtes vraiment meilleure
qu'elle est les gens se prennent à
douter
et c'est là qu'est la fameuse phrase que
celui qui n'a jamais péché et et revenge
est la première série
évidemment en fait quand on relit ses
textes à la lumière de cette ce fil
conducteur qui est la question des
doctrines du salut ça devient absolument
clair et fascinant et on comprend
pourquoi en effet la morale chrétienne a
vaincu pendant des siècles ya aussi une
autre raison c'est que l' avantage du
christianisme c'est la résurrection
c'est à dire qu'on dit aux gens non
seulement vous vous allez mourir on va
les ressusciter j'ai une chance votre
amour et votre corps va ressusciter
c'est exactement du genre c'est que au
fond ce que parce que les grecs
promettait c'est qu'on allait vaincre la
peur de la mort en s'apercevant qu'on
était un petit fragment de cosmos qu'on
était un petit atome de l'univers bon
c'est déjà pas mal mais franchement
quand vous aimez quelqu'un vous avez pas
envie de le retrouver comme fragments de
cosmos vous avez envie de le retrouver
avec sa tête que vous aimez bon alors en
discussion voudrais avoir des garanties
si c'est pour revenir comme ma carrière
dans la chambre du petit ce que le
christ va promettre et si en fait la
seule religion qui promet ça les juifs
ne ne promettent pas les musulmans ne le
premier pas il ya beaucoup de théories
de l'immortalité de l'âme
mais ce que le christ va promettre c'est
la résurrection des corps est alors
évident les gens ce temps demandé mais
attend on va renaître mais avec telle
tête à quel âge
c'est un vrai problème est la réponse du
christ au fond pour le dire simplement
c'est la réponse suivante on va renaître
avec le visage de l'amour cirque la tête
qu'on a aimé vous souvenez quand je pas
des gens sont morts vous souvenez du
visage qu'ils avaient quand vous les
aimez et c'est ça que vous allez retinne
super promesses en même temps ray bah ça
a marché mais ça marche moi j'y crois
pas mais je trouve ça quand même très
très beau c'est dur d'y croire
ouais mais c'est dur d'y croire et bien
c'est marie qu'un unique roi par exemple
mais moi j'y crois pas fier un schisme
dans le couple attend heureusement sinon
on s'ennuierait mai mais avait il
argumenté la grimace
il arrive alors on continue on continue
après après le christianisme
l humanisme alors là c'est la révolution
scientifique copernic newton des cartes
galilée et l'homme prend la place de
dieu 1 on est on est on est dans un
monde finalement du bien commun de
l'universel qui se passe autour de la
révolution scientifique en gros entre le
16ème 17ème 18ème siècle c'est que à la
fois le monde ancien le cosmos des grecs
cet ordre merveilleux que je décrivais
tout à l'heure il va s'écrouler pour un
tas de raisons qui sont compliqués je
vais pas raconter là et en même temps la
naissance de la science moderne va faire
peser un doute aussi sur la religion la
vraie particulier sur la religion
chrétienne et donc les humaine cette
époque là ils vont se retrouver sans
aucune réponse à cette fameuse question
du salut et donc ils vont être obligés
d'inventer une nouvelle réponse c'est la
fameuse phrase de pascal le silence de
ces espaces infinis m'effraie les parce
que le monde qui était comme une maison
qui était une petite niche que les grecs
habitait eh bien il a volé en éclats
sous les coups de la science moderne et
ils vont re fondé à la fois la science
la morale et de nouvelles doctrines du
salut sur l'humanité au fond savent être
nos droits de l'homme d'une façon ça va
être l'humanisme moderne et c'est aussi
évidemment une très très grande réponse
aussi à la question du salut alors ça ça
a été longtemps indépassable jusqu'à ce
qu'arrive leach il est post moderne sur
la c'est le début la déconstruction
parce que une fois que vous développer
l'esprit critique soit la science va
faire elle va développer l'esprit
critique puisqu'elle va critiquer les
visions ancien du monde elle va
critiquer les religions est donc cette
science elle va développer un formidable
esprit critique mais c'est comme l'acide
ça s'arrête pas facilement l'esprit
critique une fois que vous avez lancé la
machine critique
eh bien on va aussi critiqué les grands
idéaux que l'humanisme avait construit
les droits de l'homme la démocratie et
nietzsche il a une phrase merveilleuse
il dit il faut que les idéaux apprennent
ce qu'il en coûte d'avoir des pieds
d'argile
c'est à dire des pieds fragiles et dit
moi je vais philosopher au marteau c'est
ce qu'il appelle la déconstruction déjà
il va casser ce qu'il appelle les idoles
ou les idéaux de la métaphysique
classique pour se dire au fond le
message de la philosophie c'est d'abord
de déconstruire toutes les illusions
consolatrice pour les gens dépressifs
n'est pas à conseiller à 40
visez vous dites parce qu'ils étaient
très amoureux d'une femme merveilleuse
que beaucoup de gens ont aimé qu'ils
étaient lourds salomé qui parait-il
était absolument sublime on était un peu
fou nietzsche parce qu'il la rencontre
un soir à rome et il la demande en
mariage il la rencontre à neuf heures du
soir et la demande en mariage à 11
heures donc évidemment elle lui dit on
met deux heures ce qu'on est et là elle
un peu la trouille
si ce qu'est ce que tipi un peu
transpirant pas très beau qui va me
sauter dessus mais après il emmène en
voyage il ya des lettres magnifique où
il dit qui voudrait bien lui raconter à
quel point sa philosophie et comme de
l'acide à quel point il est des
constructrice à quel point ils cassent
les illusions et les réponses faciles à
la question du salut mais quelle comme
ils l'aiment vraiment il hésite à lui
faire du mal parce que c'est vrai que sa
philosophie est terriblement corrosive
quoi mais en même temps bon c'est une
philosophie absolument magnifique aussi
il faut de l'examiner avec une source a
aujourd'hui la philosophie contemporaine
poursuivre le travail de déconstruction
entamée par nietzsche althusser lacan
foucault deleuze derrida
alors c'est vrai qu'à la différence de
l'époque des lumières aujourd'hui on va
penser qu' on va vers le mieux car ce
qui est mort aussi cela me semble
progrès ce qui s'est passé si vous
voulez c'est pas tellement que le
progrès est mort
vous savez bien tous ici que chaque
année nos téléphones portables sont plus
performants et même si vous regardez la
médecine des choses plus sérieuses à
progresse tous les jours mais ce qui a
changé par rapport au xviiie siècle
c'est que au xviiie siècle on était
convaincu encore dans l'humanisme que
nietzsche va critiquer que le progrès
allait finalement que le progrès des
sciences aller à la fois émanciper les
humains et les rendent plus heureux et
est ce que ce que nietzsche va
évidemment kcc cette croyance au progrès
cette croyance naïve et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui là où il a d'une certaine
façon raison c'est que bien sûr nous
progressons tous les jours en un sens
sur le plan technique mais plus personne
n'est absolument certain que le progrès
est un progrès qu'on n'est pas
absolument certain qu'on est plus libre
et plus jeune a des retours de qui est
par exemple tu vois il ya des trucs qui
vont pas et donc on a le sentiment que
bon d'accord on va acheter des voitures
plus performante des téléphones
portables plus étonnant mais que c'est
pas forcément plus de liberté plus de
bonheur donc il ya un progrès
mais en même temps la vraie crise du
progrès c'est la question est ce que le
progrès est un progrès pour les
personnes n'en est absolument certain
c'est ça qui va finalement être le grand
ébranlement du 20e siècle